je ne peux pas être plus heureux en
vidéo que quand je parle du docteur
strange bon sens son second film ça fait
un moment que j'attends et il est enfin
prévu pour la phase 4 nous sommes
obligés d'en parler d'après ce qui a été
déclaré et très succinctement ce second
film serait un petit peu plus horrifique
que d'habitude pas du tout étonnant
quand on sait que le vilain du film sera
normalement nightmare soit cauchemar en
français alors ce second opus serait
directement lié à la série one la vision
du coup et elizabeth olsen et non owen
un ferait partie intégrante du film donc
il ya vraiment des choses à dire
également en termes de dimensions et
d'univers de multiverse alors n'hésite
pas à lâcher ton plus gros pouce bleus
et activer la cloche car on est parti et
d'ailleurs par curiosité
dites moi quel sorcier va devenir le
plus puissant après la phase 4 dans
l'avenir du mcs que ce serait au rwanda
où est ce que ce serait docteur strange
c'est en moi une question qui
m'intéresse allez bref on y va
[Musique]
si vous y au
le cas du rwanda est vraiment sous
cotées et bon sang vous n'imaginez pas à
quel point l'avenir du m6 va être lourd
avec le développement de ce personnage
j'aimerais pour commencer simplement
parler du pourquoi du comment la
sorcière rouge serait aux côtés de dr
strange dans son deuxième opus
et quel est le rapport avec la série one
la vision tout d'abord relier dr strange
et wendat c'est ultra intéressant
effectivement la sorcière rouge est un
personnage beaucoup plus puissants qu'on
ne pense cette dernière agit sur la
réalité par le biais de ses pouvoirs ça
c'est dans les comics mais il ya moyen
de réagir intelligemment là dessus
effectivement wendat possède des
pouvoirs contre nature elle ne les
possèdent pas depuis la naissance elle
n'a pas appris via un enseignement mais
les a acquis quand elle n'était une
cobayes d'hydra c'est une optimiser ce
que je veux dire c'est que one d'apposer
des pouvoirs contraires à ceux du
docteur en quelque sorte elle peut
manipuler la réalité des gens comme elle
le fit avec les avengers dans leur
second opus est modelé des objets les
contrôles et les déformer bref tout ce
que bordeaux souhaite combattre
tiens tiens une grande phrase du rwanda
serait judicieux a souligné la peur des
autres je n'y peux rien il n'y a que la
mienne que je contrôle
si la série one la vision est relié au
film de doctor strange 2 nous pourrons
définir plusieurs choses intéressantes
premièrement dans les comics au rwanda
possède deux enfants avec vision la
série prévue par disney et marvel se
passant après endgame nous pouvons très
clairement supposer que cela arrivera
mais ce n'est pas le plus intéressant
effectivement au rwanda a peur de ses
pouvoirs et se contrôler une grande
puissance sommeille en elle nous savons
que le méchant du film sera de cauchemar
ce dernier vient de la dimension des
rêves une dimension que les humains
atteignent pendant leur sommeil
il est tout à fait plausible voire sûr
que wendat sera tourmenté par un
événement comme par exemple la perte des
souvenirs de vision par exemple suite à
sa reconstruction après une finity
warren gay ce n'est qu'une simple idée
mais si wendat perd le contrôle à cause
de la peur il se peut que dans un excès
de colère cette dernière manipule la
réalité et ferait venir cauchemar par
erreur dans la réalité que nous
connaissons ceux qui justement accentue
cette idée que doctor strange 2 serait
techniquement le premier film d'horreur
du mc eu facile à comprendre pourquoi et
c'est à ce moment que doctor strange
interviendrait évidemment le multivers
n'est qu'une question de temps
et doctor strange est le héros parfait
pour l'introduire infos croustillantes
il était apparemment prévu que strange
envoie thanos faire une balade dans le
multivers comme l'avait fait l'ancien
avec le docteur donc c'est que le
docteur n'a plus sous le coude que l'on
pourrait le penser
stephen étant le sorcier suprême un
personnage d'une très grande sagesse le
dernier devrait renfermer la réalité de
cauchemar et apaiser le futur tourments
de la sorcière rouge
il est obligé que strange devienne comme
un père un professeur envers la jeune
protagoniste stephen pourrait lui
apprendre à contrôler et manipuler ses
pouvoirs pour en exploiter toute sa
puissance d'ailleurs si nous voulons
raisonner logiquement si loin de la
vision est une série qui se passe avant
ou pendant le second fils du docteur et
donc wendat joue dedans c'est que c'est
elle la cause du problème et de la venue
de cauchemar surtout que doctor strange
est apparemment pas forcément prévu dans
la série ce qui veut dire qu'il
n'agirait que dans son film donc il
serait l'élément de résolution et puis
le film s'appelle multiverse of madness
soit le multivers de la folie on
comprend très vite de qui on parle
dans tous les cas marvel nous prouve par
le biais de cette phase iv soit une
nouvelle introduction d'une nouvelle
histoire du mc hugh qu'ils veulent
allier certains personnages entre eux et
et créer de nouvelles relations
ainsi qu'une nouvelle équipe bon ok je
sens que ça ne vous plaît pas ça me
rappelle clairement une ancienne vidéo
et sillon de remonter le temps pour à
banamba non merde on va peut-être que
wendat peut nous permettre de changer de
réalité
non non non non non pas celle là passe
elle a vite vite
[Musique]
moi ça va ça va faire le taf
nous ne savons pas vraiment si christine
palmer sera de retour ou non pour tout
le côté amoureux du docteur mais j'ai
souvenir de vous avoir partagé dans mon
premier trois théories sur doctor
strange que scott derrickson avait
révélé quelque chose de très intéressant
effectivement ce dernier souhaite mettre
cléa à l'écran et avait à la base prévu
de le faire pour le second opus mais
c'était une possibilité difficile à
mettre à l'oeuvre dans les comics cléa
c'est l'amour du docteur strange est la
nièce de dormammu christine palmer n'est
présente que pour occuper la relation
amoureuse du docteur en attendant sa
venue
bref nous arrivons tout de même à la
phase 4 énormément de nouvelles têtes
arrivent et nous commençons à être
projeté dans un monde beaucoup plus
orienté cosmique et dimension parallèle
c'est techniquement le moment parfait
pour faire venir cléa à l'écran c'est un
personnage réellement important dans
l'histoire du docteur tout comme celui
de bordeaux ou dans mammuth alors oui le
problème c'est que cela casserait la
potentielle relations entre luanda et
stephen qui va très certainement naître
mais il se peut que cela soit juste
introduit dans ce deuxième film limites
comme une scène post générique on
parlait de bordeaux tient mort dowa
également faire son retour et devenir
plus puissant et plus dangereux mais je
ne pense pas qu'il faut le voir comme un
antagoniste principal nous savons que
pour ce deuxième opus sera cauchemar de
toute façon même hors d'eau va devenir
un ennemi secondaire récurrents et
techniquement le rival du docteur
strange
ce dernier veut réduire le nombre de
sorcier sur terre car cela crée pour lui
une instabilité dans l'univers rwanda
est clairement la plus dangereuse à ce
sujet comme je vous l'affirmé dans la
première théorie il se peut que ces
derniers affrontent cauchemars aux côtés
de strange mais que bordeaux souhaite
également l'éliminer vu sa dangerosité
par rapport au monde aux réalités et à
l' équilibre si je suis si convaincu que
bordeaux est clé apparaîtront et seront
si important c'est qu'ils sont des
protagonistes principaux des comics du
docteur strange et sont liées à dormammu
l'ennemi ultime du sort c'est suprême
dormammu reviendra forcément un jour
surtout quand il saura que strange ne
possède plus la pierre du temps ce
serait alors une potentielle relation
avec la qui pourrait sauver le docteur
en calmant son oncle ce qui est en tout
cas fascinant c'est tout ce côté
équilibres de la nature par rapport au
pouvoir des sorciers rwanda est vraiment
dangereuse pour l'univers et je me
demande vraiment comment strange va
faire pour lui à prendre le contrôle
hélas
jess bordeaux lui ne voudra pas en faire
autant et quand il découvrira que rwanda
est contre nature
il souhaitera l'éliminer au plus vite
pour continuer sans la pierre du temps
dr strange person moyens de protéger la
terre de dormammu par exemple ce dernier
se permettait de l'utiliser dans
d'autres dimensions comme la dimension
noir car le temps a très peu
d'importance dans cette dernière et ne
perturbe donc pas l'équilibré naturel de
l'univers strange maîtrise aujourd'hui
les dimensions et sans pouvoir a
augmenté lapierre n'était qu'un artefact
un bonus mais sur les 14 millions de
futurs différents strange c'est
forcément des choses sur le futur et
peut-être même du coup le poste
endgame néanmoins la question du retour
de thor mamou n'est pas à négliger et
notamment avec l'arrivée de claix a
effectivement dans les comics ce dernier
retourne vers la terre car il sent que
le sorcier suprême d'origine est en
perte de vitesse et il voit donc une
chance de le vaincre sans lapierre
strange pourrait attirer dormammu sans
le vouloir
qui aurait l'information de cette perte
bref dans tous les cas moi ce qui me lie
près de ouf c'est que justement
cauchemar va pouvoir lire les peurs les
plus profondes au rwanda et de doctor
strange puis à la dimension des rêves
voire des potentiels vérités cachées
il se pourrait que nous pourrions voir
les faiblesses et les plus grandes peurs
du docteur un retour de dormammu la
vengeance de bordeaux la mort de toni
stephen n'a cessé de nous montrer sa
puissance et sa sagesse voir ses
faiblesses nous montrerait ce côté plus
humain du sorcier suprême bon allez
pour cette dernière théorie là il me
faut une dimension encore plus folle
c'est parfait
pour terminer cette vidéo j'aimerais que
nous allons encore plus loin que ce dont
on a parlé depuis le début effectivement
les créateurs du marvel cinématiques
universe les réalisateurs etc ont
toujours une idée bien précise en tête
docteur strange n'est pas qu'un simple
nouveau héros qui grossit les rangs des
avengers
bien au contraire stephen est le sorcier
suprême celui qui amène la magie dans le
mc eu mais aussi et surtout le multivers
est encore plus important il est le
héros pour les réalisateurs qui sera un
énorme piliers de la phase 4 et
l'intriguent de cette dernière il est
vrai le concept de magie est enfin à
portée mais encore rien par rapport aux
multivers et dieu sait que les
dimensions parallèles sont au coeur des
comics et de l'histoire originelle de
marvel et du docteur strange
j'aimerais que nous parlions de la
pierre du temps et de son propriétaire
le concept de l'oeil d'agde à moto est
empli de mystères dans le mc eu échange
énormément des comics
effectivement dans le mc eu l'oeil est
en fait représenter par le pendentif du
docteur mais également et surtout par la
pierre du temps et comme vous le savez
strange a dû léguer la pierre du temps à
thann hausses qui là détruisit après son
premier ce n'a pas puis l'autre pierre
du temps appartient au passé et se
devaient de retourner à son époque
donc bref vous avez compris l'idée quoi
strange ne possède plus son arme ultime
et surtout ne possède plus ce pourquoi
les sorciers suprême se bat l'oeil est
présent depuis le tout premier sur ses
suprêmes et est une arme permettant de
défendre la terre face à des menaces
externes comme dormammu par exemple et
c'est là que la problématique intervient
et devient intéressante
est-ce que dr strange est toujours
légitime à sa condition de sorcier
suprême et va-t-il devenir inutile du
coup dans les comics l'oeil est associée
à la vision de la vérité et à la magie
blanc seul un être pur comme le docteur
avec des intentions claires peut le
manipuler
contrairement au mc ucal
symbolisation a été changé pour les
films bien que le réceptacle de la
pierre du temps ne peut être ouvert que
par strange c'est la pierre qui est
importante
rv avec thanos qui a pu s'en servir avec
ses mauvaises intentions
c'est une pierre d'infinité après tout
mais cela ne veut pas dire que strange
naples une ambition et va s'éteindre au
contraire hague à moto le premier
sorcier suprême avait créé trois objets
mystique qui réunit sont appelés les
yeux d'agde à moto l'oeil étant le plus
puissant et le troisième oeil celui qui
peut voir la vérité dans l'idée c'est
comme ça que dr strange a pu voir les 14
millions de futurs différend avec
l'unique possibilité de vaincre thanos
une vérité mais du futur par rapport au
concept de la pierre du temps bref le
second objet est associé aux concepts
clés du pouvoir
si je ne me trompe pas et c'est la
colonne vertébrale d'agde à moto puis le
dernier celui qui nous intéresse et le
globe d'agde à moto cette fois-ci liée
au concept de la prescience
alors oui ce concept dérange un peu car
dans le mc où nous pourrions l'associé
également la pierre du temps permettant
de voir les événements à venir mais je
pense qu'il faut plutôt voir ce concept
par rapport aux dimensions
effectivement le globe d'agde à moto est
un objet qui a déjà été montré dans le
mc eu mais très brièvement le globe ou
leur blog à moto est situé à carthage
soit le sanctuaire des sanctuaires
là où l'ancien se tenait quand il a
accueilli strange plus exactement dans
la chambre des ombres dans le mc u7 orb
et présentée comme simple objet
permettant de surveiller les trois
sanctuaires celui de londres new york et
hong kong qui eux permettent de défendre
la terre face à des menaces comme
dormammu mais c'est un objet qui peut
avoir un tout autre sens l'orb permet
dans les comics au docteur de se
transporter dans des dimensions
extérieures et détecter des dangers liés
à la magie si multivers il doit y avoir
orbe d'agde à moto il y aura marvel
souhaite aller encore plus loin que ce
qui nous a été présenté les quatre
premières phases et doivent donc mettre
les moyens pour renforcer l'histoire
d'agde à moto dans les comics est pour
moi très important pour l'avenir du
docteur car des objets lui appartenant
son canonisé dans le mc eu strange est
présenté comme un élu des sorciers je
cite le meilleur d'entre nous nombreux
sont les objets camotos a créé dans les
comics et ont servi au docteur l'orb
permettrait d'atteindre la dimension
des rêves pour vaincre cauchemar qui est
l'un des plus grands ennemis du docteur
et même de pouvoir s'élargir hors de la
terre hors de sa réalité
j'aimerais enfin souligné à quel point
dormammu et sous côtés et à quel point
strange est très loin de pouvoir se
mesurer à lui pour le moment dormammu et
la représentation de la destruction et
grâce à la dimension noir permet de se
modélise et comme il nous l'a été montré
dans mamour une sacrée importance dans
l'avenir du mc eu notamment la phase 5
et aurait les capacités de devenir le
méchant ultime de cette phase j'aimerais
accentuer le fait que dormammu dans sa
conception pour le premier film du
docteur a été fait pour ressembler à
strange benedict cumberbatch a même
prêté sa voix au méchant et le visage
ressemble beaucoup à celui du docteur
tout ça pour qu'il représente le côté
obscur justement du docteur c'est à quel
point le docteur et dormammu sont liés
et grandes seront les batailles entre
les deux protagonistes
mais nous ne sommes pas encore là pour
le moment
j'espère sincèrement que la vidéo vous
aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à la chaîne à me suivre sur
twitter ou instagram et petites
nouveautés sachez que si ce t-shirt
spider man vous intéresse vous pourrez
le retrouver avec un autre également
dans la description et du coup si vous
souhaitez l'acheter n'hésitez pas à
utiliser le code promo argot 15 qui va
réduire du coût de 15 pour cent
vos achats sur toast à doha bon je sais
que ça peut déranger certains mais je
trouve vraiment que les tisseurs de chez
toast à doha sont vraiment de qualité et
moi en tant que ben non je ne suis plus
étudiant du coup il faut que je me
démerde maintenant eh ben ça me permet
d'être ma porte est potentiellement un
petit revenu
si certains achètent des t-shirts donc
c'est toujours un plus et en plus sinon
ça me facture gratuit donc voilà bref
c'était targue rock et que le lay
honneur soit avec vous
[Musique]
tiens mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
dimension aéro sétois aéro
je suis venu marchander et merde